also die korona pandemie hat mich sehr
hart getroffen als solo sänger künstler
muss ich glaube ich keinem erzählen wie
das ist wenn alles zugemacht wird und
wenn man dann auf einmal vor einem
scherbenhaufen steht und nicht mehr weiß
wie man seine miete bezahlen muss dann
ist es schon echt nicht das geilste
gefühl das man haben kann also ich hatte
glaube ich drei mal zusammenbruch war
ich echt existenzangst hatte da wo ich
echt nicht wusste wie zahle ich ein
bisschen nächsten monat meine miete
bezahle ich meine um kosten
in der ich bin rené ich bin 28 jahre und
ich finde vom beruf entertainer
und jetzt bin ich die kunstfigur lag
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin generation merkel weil sie immer
zur wahl stand sie war immer sehr ruhig
sie hat immer ihren kurs gefahren immer
ihr ding gemacht aber sie hat sich auch
öffentlich entschuldigt wenn sie einen
fehler gemacht hat und ich finde das
zeigt auch vom größer ich finde sehr
guten job gemacht sie musste schwierige
entscheidungen treffen und ich glaube
schon dass sie fehlen wird ja heute ist
wieder einiges zu tun
cool des modus anders sie sind muss ich
auch selber schon lassen
heute arbeitet
jones war und am wochenende auch
[Musik]
es ist so verrückt man eigentlich gebe
ich ein zwei welten diskutieren und es
gibt lecks zwischendrin von mexiko setzt
dem eine ganz klare könnte das heißt
wenn ich den text elo kamerad bin ich in
meinem lag cielo modus da bin ich laut
und wenig frech dann mache ich dumme
sprüche und als rené bin ich schon eher
ruhiger 60 hat mich tatsächlich
verholfen meine schüchternheit abzulegen
wenn du entertainer bist bist du immer
irgendeine figur box bei den kindern ist
das ist ein pirat ein bisschen clown ob
es auch im kiez ist der bisher jungen
beim bummel auf dem kopf und das ist
halt immer eine rolle das hat mir halt
geholfen mich so zu akzeptieren wie ich
bin nicht so zu lieben wie ich bin und
hat auch viel selbstsicherheit zu machen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ich mache gerade mich fertig für
den heutigen tag und
überlege gerade
welches ich von diesen vier
wunderschönen kostümen ich heute
mitnehme ins altersheim wir gehen heute
wieder auf altersheim tour ich habe im
ersten quarter und angefangen nicht
ehrenamtlich zu engagieren weil ich halt
einfach finde man sollte von seinem
glück was zurückgeben was man in seinem
eigenen leben hat und man sollte in der
gesellschaft versuchen zu helfen das ist
eigentlich auch mein lieblings jacke
die ist ein bisschen voll geknallt und
da wir den omis und opis ja heute auch
ordentlich etwas bieten wollen
nehmen wir die jacke mit politisch
gesehen hat man natürlich viel
entschieden man hat natürlich geguckt
was verbietet man was laut hartmann ich
hab halt geguckt dass ich über die
runden komme man das erstmal mein leben
gesichert ist und dann habe ich halt
getan oder hab ich halt geguckt dass ich
was gutes tun kann und habe den menschen
essen gebracht die halt nicht rausgehen
konnten oder bin halt in die alten
heimat für die wieder gesungen
[Musik]
mit dem ersten block dann hat mich das
tatsächlich sehr hart getroffen weil man
konnte auf einmal kein geld mehr
verdienen man hatte keine aufträge mehr
und dementsprechend stand ich schon vor
dem scherbenhaufen der geprägt war mit
existenzängsten und man wusste nicht so
genau okay wie geht es jetzt weiter ich
hätte mir von der politik ein bisschen
offenheit gewünscht dass die einen so
ein bisschen mal mit rein schauen lassen
was besprechen die gerade aber für mich
gab es halt einfach immer wieder
enttäuschende momente und dann wurde
halt einfach nicht über die gastronomie
gesprochen die gastronomie wurde hat
einfach vergessen und damit wurden wir
künstler vergessen dann habe ich gedacht
jetzt schon voraus jetzt machen wir noch
und dann begraben weil ex bilde und dann
war's das aber glücklicherweise ist es
soweit dann doch nicht gekommen
[Musik]
bestehen
ich habe das große glück dass ich ganz
ganz tolle freunde haft die mir unter
die arme gegriffen haben und gesagt
haben hier kommen dann hast du erst mal
geld gibt es mir zurück wenden wenn es
passt und als die politik dann endlich
die hilfsgelder beschlossen hat fand ich
waren sehr großzügig
75% später 80 prozent vom jahresumsatz
auszubezahlen hat wirklich gut geholfen
ich habe die korona pandemie überlebt
zwar mit zwei blauen augen aber ich habe
es überlebt
schönen guten tag
wir sind das begrüßungskomitee für den
persönlichen daten sehen hör auf zu
wenig freuen danke dass ihr wieder da
seid mal warten ja ich weiß wie so ein
bisschen schwer ich arbeite mit längst
wieder zusammen auf der reeperbahn daher
kennen wir uns und jetzt hat er mich
gefragt ob ich gerne mit in das
altenheim möchte weil sie die tour
mitmachen und bei sowas schöne mich
natürlich dabei sein wir hatten jetzt in
letzter zeit nicht so viel die
möglichkeit uns auf der bühne zu
präsentieren es wir lieben ja auch
unseren job und so haben wir gedacht so
kann man das eine mit dem anderen
verbinden dass wir freude am performen
haben und gleichzeitig leute die nicht
die möglichkeit dazu haben jetzt gross
auf der reeperbahn feiern zu gehen dass
wir einfach die reeperbahn zu denen
bringen
so ihr lieben ich
musste für mich denn ich kannte ihn gar
nicht ich musste erst mal googeln wer
den längsten überhaupt ist
dementsprechend konnten wir uns ein
bisschen vorbereiten aber ich bin im
endeffekt nachher total positiv
überrascht
[Musik]
in den altersheimen habe ich natürlich
auch mit vielen menschen mal unterhalten
und dann haben wir halt schon viele
erzählt dass sie sich schon über die
diesen besuch gefreut haben was man auch
nicht vergessen darf ist pflegepersonal
was in einem pflegenotstand ist und die
irgendwie gefühlte 24 stunden im
altersheim sind weil sie dann einfach
mal eine stunde ausschalten konnten
entspannen konnten und auch unterteilt
werden konnten
sind sich der welt dich wieder alles
[Musik]
für eine
capitaland
habt ihr sie gerecht
[Applaus]
bleibt bitte alle genauso toll und
zauber wir seit bleibt gesund und dann
würde ich sagen sehen wir uns sehr sehr
bald wieder ob ihr wollt oder nicht dass
mir gar nicht kommen wieder
ich schlief nicht mehr einfach irgendwas
mit einer trotzdem schön ja da bin ich
sehr ruhig ganz weg ganz haben sie
begeistert das ist schön dass
hingefallen da machen wir ein foto ja
sehr gerne das ist super ich passt gut
dieses haus es ist toll dass junge leute
für uns etwas machen und uns freude
bringen und das hier ablenkungen haben
freunde der sonne vielleicht die heutige
dreh location zeigen es ist die schönste
die ganze mit
[Musik]
komma und volksbank stadion der fußball
bedeutet für mich eine ganze menge
fußball ist nicht nur leidenschaft und
emotionen fußball ist auch ein hobby 1
ausgleich ich liebe es einfach zum
spieltag zu gehen mich mit meinen
freunden zu treffen auf der nord grünen
stehen 1 212 bier zu trinken den hsv
anzufeuern und hat einfach einen schönen
sonntag zu haben ich bin total
geselliger mensch und liebe es halt
einfach mit einem freund unterwegs zu
sein und fußball ist da halt einfach die
schönste nebenbeschäftigung der welt
[Musik]
seit dem studium arbeitet hier also ich
bin glaube ich jetzt schon fünf jahre
hier im betrieb immer als aushilfe das
heißt natürlich auch dass ich immer sehr
flexibel bin das heißt ich habe hier das
große glück dass ich hier so arbeiten
kann wie ich tatsächlich zeit habe und
es ist mal mehr mal weniger liegt aber
halt auch einfach daran dass es manchmal
natürlich viel zu tun gibt auf dem kiez
dann kann ich hier weniger arbeiten und
wenn du es auf dem kiez weniger zu tun
wird kann ich hier einfach mehr arbeiten
das heißt es ist der perfekte ausgleich
das ist tatsächlich was ich nicht kann
was ja ich weiß nicht warum so packen
wird dieser krise komme ich einfach nie
klar los wir müssen das jetzt so andrea
kommt das so rum
und dann hierdurch der wahnsinn ja die
konstante hsv ist in meinem leben
natürlich sehr wichtig weil jetzt nicht
nur job ist sondern auch leidenschaft
ist mein ausgleich zu lecks dildo das
liebe ich einfach und auch vor anderen
seite kann man da noch ein paar taler
extra verdienen kann sein gehalt ein
bisschen aufbessern und ich finde es
einfach großartig dass sich jobs ab wo
ich total stolz drauf bin und sagen kann
das ist nicht nur arbeit das ist auch
leidenschaft
[Musik]
ich glaube dass man diese beiden welten
fußball und reeperbahn gar nicht
miteinander vereinen kann weil das ist
so ein bisschen ähnlich wilex und rené
ist diese fußball die sportwelt und
längst ist halt diese schrille bunte
vogel reeperbahn welt beide kreuzen sich
zwar immer mal wieder wieso zwei kreise
die einander eingehen aber niemals
übereinstimmen weiß dann einfach doch
zwei welten sind
es ist gerade sehr beeindruckend für
mich ist es auf einer seite schon
traurig so ein leeres stadion zu sehen
normalerweise volles haus tolle ränge
stimmung und jetzt gerade ist leere
stadion das ist schon halt auf eine
gewisse art und weise traurig war ich
hätte nie gedacht dass es mal so weit
kommen kann man fragt sich ja immer
selber was hätte man selber anders
entschieden oder was hatte man selber
anders gemacht aber ich bin halt auch
manchmal wirklich ehrlich und sage ich
bin froh dass diese entscheidung nicht
treffen musste
[Musik]
der moment als ich gehört habe dass
gelockert wurde und das ist endlich
wieder losgeht war tatsächlich
unbeschreiblich ich konnte es erst gar
nicht glauben die leute kommen zurück
das passieren weitere lockerungsschritte
und ich bin jetzt einfach helfe ich bin
so euphorisiert dass es wieder losgeht
und vor allem was man halt auch nicht
vergessen darf bei aller liebe und
leidenschaftlich hier auf der reeperbahn
habe dass man endlich wieder einen job
hat man dass man endlich wieder weiß
okay ich verdiene jetzt geld und ich
komme nicht von morgen auf heute wieder
ein existenzängste oder in schieflagen
weil das ist halt wirklich das
schlimmste gefühl das es gibt wenn du
nicht mehr weiß wie du deine miete
bezahlen kannst
alex de ist jemand der wirklich sehr gut
in die olivia jones familie baesweiler
extrovertiert ist aber weil er auch
genau unsere werte hat weil er für eine
offene bunte republik steht wegen
diskriminierung gegen bodyshaping und
wir sind einfach so dass wir so leben
die wir gerne leben möchten und eines
haben wir im blut das entertainment und
der ist wirklich eine rampensau und
deswegen bin ich ganz froh dass er bei
uns ist weil er ist einfach ein toller
entertainer
ich hoffe natürlich auch dass wir dann
von woche zu woche weiter planen können
weiter lockern können unsere konzepte
anpassen können so dass jeder ganz
sicher feiern kann und wir irgendwann
wieder zurück zum alten leben sind
sondern auch jeder wieder tanzen kann
bis in den morgen ihr wollt
ich hab da hinten den tisch frei
das stand aber auf den test karten
anderer namen
so macht ihr eine menge platz heiß und
fettig mehrheit
von der neuen bundesregierung wünsche
ich mir dass wir künstler und
schausteller sichtbarer werden dass wir
gesehen werden dass wir gehört werden
und dass man nicht manchmal das gefühl
hat dass man nicht an uns denken sondern
dass man sagt wir haben jetzt gerade
keine lockerung für euch aber wir denken
an euch und wir gucken dass es bald geht
heißt seit einfach offen redet mit uns
und jeder politiker ist jederzeit
eingeladen nach seinem pulli zu kommen
und mit uns irgendwelche regeln zu
bestimmen weil ihr seht selber es gibt
keine konzepte mit denen wir sichern
feiern können und wir freuen uns einfach
wenn man uns gedacht wird und wir mit
ins boot geholt werden können
[Musik]
ihr lieben wenn euch das gefallen hat
dann schaut doch einfach mal in der
mediathek denn da gibt's noch mehr
[Musik]